yes thank you very much
um this is the first of two talks in a
row here about polars and as said it's
an opinionated introduction so basically
my opinion so you might want to know a
little bit about the guy who wants to
talk to you about his opinion so I'm a
data scientist working for sinus doing
all kind of consultancy machine learning
data engineering this kind of stuff
and I'm doing this kind of data work for
10 years kind of now and starting back
an hour and then quickly switching to
Python and since then I was always kind
of wrangling mutating some kind of data
mostly in pandas as probably most of you
and also a lot of spark in the early
days and since then I tried a couple of
different Frameworks so task modern
whatever but recently I discovered polas
and this one really got me excited and
yes that's the reason why I want to talk
to you about it
so if you think like okay there are so
many Frameworks why should we care maybe
for the same reason I cared because I
was scrolling through Twitter and then I
saw these benchmarks coming by where I
thought
that looks cheesy that looks kind of too
good to be true like how can something
be like that much faster on something
where so many libraries already try to
do it that fast and
um yeah so I tried it out myself so
basically if you look there there's like
a small tiny bar in Violin Violet and
that's basically the time it takes
polars to run certain queries in some
well-known Benchmark regarding
analytical workloads and
um yeah to take that ahead I also
discovered a great increase of speed
with polars maybe not that crazy but
still like four to five times and this
is a game changer if something in pandas
runs before for you like 10 seconds some
query and then it takes only two that
really changed quite some stuff
so how can this be possible how can
products be so much faster
well pandas isn't perfect and that's
well known so West McKinney the author
basically stated by himself that when he
started founding and developing pandas
he didn't know too much about software
engineering and the architecture and so
in the beginning he did some things he
probably wouldn't have done later again
and he led them out in a nice blog post
already back in 2017 and in this blog
post he highlighted actually 11 points
of things he hated in pandas and he
would like to change and this is a long
list so I don't want to go over all of
them right now but we will take that
list along with us across the talk and
go over those different points and they
are really different so some are
regarding speed like parallelization or
memory management others are also the
not so well support of categorical
values or missing data and so already
2017 six years ago West McKinney stated
that he co-founded actually Apache arrow
and at that point when pandas integrates
Arrow completely you might call that
pandas2o this is basically what happened
just a couple of weeks ago with the
official release of pandas2o and um
yeah so what is Apache error Apache
arrow is a library a lot of other
libraries use under the hood these days
and they mostly do that for performance
so arrow is basically a standardization
of in memory
data format and for analytical workloads
so basically columnar but it's not only
a standardization it's also a lot of
basically drivers or libraries to
implement this in different in different
languages and thereby different
Frameworks even written for example
spark running in a Java runtime can
access exactly the same data such as
polars or pandas in the new version now
with arrow under the hood and thereby
exchanging data and it did a lot of
things better than pandas does so for
example it supports missing values by
default it has a much faster string
support a lot of that stuff is already
mentioned two talks ago in the pandas
talk
so
this is all great and by implementing
this in pandas 2 if you use that because
I mean you have to name those columns
explicitly that you want to use Arrow
under the hood with pandas2 but if you
use that a lot of those problems already
go away so you have now a good support
for missing data so integers are not
automatically converted to floats
anymore if you have a none once in there
or that cheesy Stuff and
yeah so a lot of stuff will go away it's
easier to append data category with the
support
but polas has that has that as well and
all the other libraries we saw before
have that because
basically pandas is rather a late
adapter there than an early one
let's go a little bit over those
different points and how they can result
in such a speed up
so one thing when we talk about speed is
always simdi instructions so single
instruction multiple data the idea is
pretty simple basically instead of
handling every row after every row again
you do an operation or all of them in
one bulk together that's much much
faster and that's also what made pandas
fast since the early days
and this is also what you break if you
make pandas apply and apply some some
Lambda functions basically this will
dramatically decrease your performance
so always try to avoid this never well
as often as you can try to use not use
pandas apply Lambda or whatever
but this is a little bit tricky with
with pandas and basically in polas
that's a little bit better for that
let's have a look on how the polar
syntax actually looks like
for those
um it might be maybe a little bit
confusing the most project before we
talked about or which raised up
they
they basically try to imitate the panda
syntax and polas doesn't do that polar
looks more like spark maybe but also has
some formal familiarity with uh with
pandas so you create a couple of data
frames and the major difference there is
that you don't have any indexes polus
doesn't use indexes at all
basically they are not needed often it
gets confusing anyway and you select by
some filters whatever and not
necessarily over the indexes so
basically you have a numeric index
that's all
and what pandas polas use a lot is the
with columns that's your go-to functions
whenever you either want to mutate a
column or whether you want to add an
additional column so in here we are
adding a new column and this column
shouldn't be based on an existing but
rather of a value of stars so what I did
here for this small example I scraped
together the Stars some popular python
libraries have on GitHub and the number
of pull requests just to have some data
and as I want to append them I want to
have this additional column so basically
with with column and plit I'm creating a
new column basically there of all the
different of stars and giving it the
name metric
basically by specifying an alias
and then I'm appending or concatenating
those two data frames and I'm sorting
them
good to mention there there's nothing
like sort values or so because we don't
have indexes so basically sort always
requires some column or multiple columns
to sort by
okay now we have some data frames we
want also to use this expressive API and
do some classical aggregations so what
we're doing here is basically again the
width column
to add some additional columns and here
we select a couple of those normally for
that you always use this PL for polars
DOT call to the select a couple and then
you decide what to do so for example
here I'm creating a diff of always the
row before and the next row
to see basically how the stars have
changed over the years
and one
yeah and other so normally this would
overwrite the existing columns so I need
to give it a new name so to add those
columns and therefore I'm using the
prefix function to give it a new name
and one really nice and tactical sugar
in there is the over keyword over allows
you to create some boundaries so
normally if I'm using the diff function
for example every row is going to the
next and looking what's the difference
there but we don't want to create a
difference over different metrics so
there we want to have a split and
therefore we use the over keyboard then
it creates those this boundary and will
not create a wrong
value which doesn't make sense
normally in pandas you would need to
create a group buyer and then later join
that and so this way it's much faster
and by using the syntax we gain actually
a lot of different benefits so
um
some takeaways polos doesn't has indexes
it has a really powerful expression API
the over keyword is nice and something
which I didn't mention yet is that it
supports both an eager and a lazy
execution
so eager is what you know from pandas
basically calculating everything at the
point where you
kind of enter yourself for example in
the Jupiter notebook and the lazy mode
is well known from spark where you
basically create a graph in the
background of all the different
computations you want to get but it's
only actually calculated at the point
when you call a collect function in the
end
and this has a big benefit because it
can be much much faster so the great
thing for example here in this example
which is an obvious one is that normally
if you make like an eager mode you have
first to read all the data and then we
show the first five lines but if we have
a lazy mode
we say please read the data and give me
the first five lines and then it starts
going back and realize okay I don't need
to read the full data I can just take
the beginning and then stop because I
don't need more and this is one obvious
idea how you can save a lot of time
there
but there's much more you can do with
such a lazy mode so by query
optimization you can do Branch
predictions so basically guess
beforehand which data you will need next
for your operations and thereby reduce
cash misses so there are some nice blog
posts of the author of polars how we
spend a lot of time basically to reduce
them so a cache Miss is if you load like
data into your pipeline of your CPU
cache which you don't need then you have
to basically drop that and get other
data from the RAM and that takes time
and by doing all those different things
you can save a lot of time which is only
allowed by using another syntax because
pandas by default is eager and you
couldn't do that optimizations within
ego mode
so as said thereby we're optimizing here
the eagle evaluation which was a problem
with pandas back then and
also the complex Group by operations
which are slow can get much faster but
for this we need to think about
parallelization so
um
fertilization can be basically done by
or basically you can have no
polarization such as old Partners or you
can also try to parallelize things and a
lot of libraries do that but It's Tricky
it's you can get stuck at some point and
maybe you don't know what will happen
then
yeah
good motivations but you have to do it
right so
there is an easy way basically when you
have like different calculations which
are clearly separated and they don't
need to communicate with each other then
it's an easy thing then you can
basically use a classical old map reduce
paradigm what do you do when you have
like data that needs some kind of
communication between them so there are
different ideas you could basically take
the whole data frame and maybe if you
have two workers then the first half
goes to the first half worker to the
sector after the second
but maybe you have some certain Keys
which fall into both workers and then
the aggregations are invalid so you need
some kind of synchronization step
afterwards to make them valid and that
takes a lot of time
okay if that's a problem we just allow
them to communicate so again to workers
both load the first loads the first half
the single second and they have some
common interface some
um thing where they can basically both
access and block each other that works
maybe for two workers but if you have
more workers the blocking gets a harder
problem if they all operate on the same
storage so that might also be not the
ideal solution
what polos does is basically every
worker reads the full data because data
can be read easily and fast by using
Apache error under the hood everything
is in memory anyway and then within the
operation the worker decide whether they
are responsible for this park or part of
of data so basically the calculator hash
them a hash value and then a Motorola
function and thereby they decide whether
this point of data is within their
responsibility
so thereby you can make sure that
certain Keys only fall into exactly one
worker and then in the end you can just
make a simple concatenate and you have
all your data
what we will lose by this is basically
the order but order you will realize if
you use polars is something kind of
flexible so the the things get changed
the order quite often so you have to get
used to if you have something that is
order relevant sorted first but still
it's much much faster this way and it
can parallelize nicely
so by doing this we also have now a
library that really by default tries to
use all your CPU cores they can get
and they are like the first two points
which are really kind of like yeah
something special so uh West McKinney
stated that pandas is kind of far away
from the real metal there and cannot do
all the optimizations and also he says
yeah memory map data sets would be nice
and
polar
yeah polas has all that as well so
basically polas is written in Rust which
is not just super super fast because
it's this language similar to C but
either to program
um but it also you don't have any
dependencies
and that's a nice feeling seriously when
you pip install something and the
dependency resolution basically is just
not necessary because there are no
dependencies
so of course in reality you will have
some things you want to operate together
and so but it's a nice thing
another thing is that polas doesn't
scale across multiple servers so it's
not like task also which runs on big
clusters is running on a sim a single
machine but it's using all the cores in
there and with cloud computing you can
easily get quite big machines
and if your data is still too large for
it and you cannot operate on all of them
at the same time you can basically do an
out of memory operation so what it does
is basically it in a lazy mode it scans
some data set applies some
transformation on it and then writes it
to another data set and by this it can
operate on smaller chunks of the data
and work on it
this is not possible for all the
different operations so you cannot do
everything with it but still it's
something pretty nice to be able to work
on data which doesn't fit into your
memory
and
um yeah by doing this we also got rid of
the first two points and we kind of
settled the full list of this McKinney
of things he kind of wanted to see in
such a library
but basically that's not all the parts I
would like to see so this is now my
personal summary of what I like about
polars and not so much so
polus is great for its speed so really
it's much faster Try It Out by yourself
I thought of keep showing you some
notebooks where I run different cells in
the timing but just try it on your own
data you will see that it is really fast
I personally love the support of both of
eager and lazy mode because it depends
on what you do from my point of view if
I'm developing something in a notebook I
like the eager mode because it gives me
the direct feeling how long is something
running is it maybe not as I expected I
have a better feeling for the data and
operations later because I see how they
are running and actually this way for me
it's faster because it's running in this
time while I'm thinking about the next
cell and it's not just running at the
point when I'm basically finished with
thinking and now it needs to calculate
everything so for that I like the eager
mode but of course if you're doing
something in production it's much faster
with the lazy mode and you can easily
switch
the expression API of polars is also
pretty nice it takes you some time to
get used to it so um you probably need
to spend a few hours if you're well
known to spark it's easier
um
the the way paulas is written is also a
little bit different I would say it's a
little bit more verbose you often use
this PL dot something
um but for that maybe it's also a little
bit more maintainable so I think it's
pretty good readable and therefore
better maintainable but it's a little
bit more of typing which is for
production code probably a good
trade-off
on the other hand they are something
that I don't like so much about polar so
as that I'm a data scientist so I'm
doing a lot of explorative work in some
Jupiter notebooks and stuff and then I
often for example don't know my data
frame so well yet so I want to try it
out so what I'm doing is I'm having my
data frame and Inner Cell I'm typing DF
Dot and I get my column names by Auto
completion and I don't remember them
exactly how to write them and this
doesn't work with polars and polos you
always have to explicitly name as a
string somehow which columns you want to
operate on probably there will be some
workarounds maybe later or so but
currently this blocks me in the way I
would like to operate while doing
explorative work with it
it doesn't do any of the nice pandas
ecosystem around so it has no plotting
functionality not this slice
highlighting and visualizing of data
frames and also the compatibility with
other libraries like second floor and
pathogen so it's not there yet so it if
you basically load data from there send
it to one Library take it to the next
Library you will often need to transfer
to pandas between and maybe then Polaris
is not the best best trade-off
um yeah and pandas is a little bit more
typing efficient but yeah I think that's
kind of like a feeling so
if you have something where performance
is critical and where you probably also
have like a big data set which takes
some time to run give polos a try it
takes some time to load but I really
like it for this now if you're doing
explorative work or basically using
pandas to glue different things together
I think maybe it's not the best choice
yet
and that's basically my personal summary
of it here are some more Links of
basically where I got the information
from
the next talk here will be also a little
bit more not comparing to pandas but
also a lot of duckdb stuff I hope at
least
and yeah then I'm happy to get your
questions thanks
[Applause]
thank you Nico so we have already a lot
of questions uh the first question is
how stable is Polaris would you
recommend it using it in production code
and client projects yeah so that was
exactly what I wanted to find out myself
so because basically I got the link like
one and a half year ago of a friend
really early these days
um and he said yeah do you want to give
it a try and I tried it and basically a
lot of things didn't work out and I was
really excited how many issues I needed
to file while testing polars and I
didn't have to I had to ask to stack
Overflow questions because I didn't get
stuff by the side of that I didn't need
to file any issues yet
um
so I think if if maybe not like the the
most important system yet because of
course always start with the the small
ones but I would give it a try also for
production workloads here
okay next question no dependencies does
it actually have no dependencies or are
all the all of them in Rust and we just
do not have any visibility into them
being outdated and insecure
okay so definitely there are
dependencies yes they are in Rust you
don't just see them
um whether they are outdated of course
that might happen if the project gets
stale some point or so but if you at
least see the course development
everything is really active a lot of
things new releases coming by every day
so um currently I would say the stuff
doesn't get outdated there but yeah they
are just somewhere else that's true okay
why did polas ditch indexing
so basically the argument of that you
think the author is that you just don't
need it so um he says it doesn't give
you a real benefit of performance
because you also need to maintain and
build this index and thereby often use
copying and stuff with pandas you don't
have that so it doesn't give you a
performance boost and also From
usability perspective to be honest I
also mostly filter about the columns and
not really about the indexes but that
might depend on how you use your
framework here
when would you say is it worth to
migrate a large Panda based code base to
polars
I would say if
um the speed is not enough for you so
basically if you get annoyed by the time
it takes to run or you're having
problems with memory then I would give
it a try I mean otherwise if everything
works for you why should you migrate it
would it be considered bad practice to
cast between polars pandas data frames
within the same code base when using pi
Arrow back end I don't think so so
basically I think that will be the
future also much more by more libraries
basically implementing this per arrow
thing under the hood that you can really
easily switch between them and maybe not
for every single transformation but if
you have like a lot a bigger
transformation here and then need some
Library which is only supported in
Partners yet I think there's nothing
against
um yeah switching between them it
doesn't come with a lot of or like
almost no cost
okay how do you configure how many CPUs
pullers use
so by default it takes all it can get
but you can configure it somewhere I
cannot take it out of my mind but it's
in the documentation
okay the API looks quite strongly typed
I.E things like PL dot column column one
column two is there a way also use
attribute accesses to get nice Auto
completion
so if there's something out there I
would be really curious in it I'm
missing exactly this
um I'm not aware of it yet let's see
what will happen in the future you don't
always have to use the peer call so
often there are some like smaller or
shorter versions which are not the first
one written in the documentation but
which are also official like basically
just using the strings instead of PL
colon so but Auto completion for column
names for example that's exactly what
I'm missing yeah
how does polars compare to data table in
terms of speed and functionality
so if you take the benchmarks it's kind
of
no data tables
um
I think it's kind of the same area but
um yeah I personally didn't use data
table so I cannot really compare it by
myself
when you look at the performance
Benchmark I think it's kind of the same
area of speed maybe a little bit faster
but yeah that depends on what Benchmark
you're looking at
okay next question how does polars
compare to Pi Spark
so basically it has some familiar
familiarity with the syntax but aside of
that there's different things so yeah um
spark scales across big cluster
therefore it comes with a higher latency
of getting data in and out and stuff so
it's therefore like really big workloads
and polars is kind of like coming more
as a replacement for pandas for the
small stuff but being able to also scale
more into the direction of of spark but
of course spark can handle bigger data
sets than polos yes
would you recommend polars for time
series where all the matter
where order meta so yeah you can do a
lot of Time series Transformations there
as well
um
I didn't try it too much whether you
often need to sort it by something there
yeah to be honest I'm not sure about it
before I would need to dig a little bit
into it so you say yes he said so the
next talk will be about it so the
questionnaire can stay okay
um how does John operation work in cases
where need a full data data frame fit in
memory
[Music]
um
I can only guess that it might reach
single columns so basically if you're
having a lazy API and you're only also
the same way we had in the example with
the head only the first rows you can do
the same basically with columns so
basically just if you just mention
certain columns it will read only those
ones from pakir and therefore you of
course reduce your memory requirement
um
but what if this one still doesn't match
into that and you want to use the out of
memory I don't know I didn't test it
okay how hard is it to migrate large use
cases from pandas to polars
so it this is not like you just take it
and five minutes later you're finished
you if you know it it's doable and
probably and similar will soon probably
help us there I guess even that for
polars it doesn't work so well yet
probably because of the old age but
[Music]
um
yeah
um it takes some time to to transform it
yeah you have to rewrite basically
everything kind of
uh Wendy when When developing a library
how do you decide on the syntax grammar
of the library example while very
similar to Pi spark polar still has some
differences
okay I didn't get the question how the
question was uh when uh when the
developing a library how do you decide
on a syntax grammar of the library
okay I'm sorry I don't really get that
maybe come to me talk later and we can
have it in a direct discussion
how powerful is the execution
optimization is it comparable to spark
the execution optimization
um
so
probably it depends a lot on on your
workloads but from my point of view it's
much faster than Spark
okay thank you give a warm-up plus to
Nico
thanks